We're back blue. Tell us who you are.
I am Bruce Burningham. And where do you teach?
I teach at Illinois State University. This is Radiolab. I'm Jad. I'm Robert.
So Bruce, he's a a scholar, a language professor.
And I called him up because Jed and I were having a little disagreement,
friendly one. Okay. We're having an argument here.
I said that when you get the hip hop in the wrestling and the novels and all
that, you're getting a sort of a a moment,
contemporary moment where people are fascinated by authenticity.
And then Jad my partner says, I don't know,
maybe people have always been interested in authenticity.
And this has just comes with being a human. It's nothing about now,
it just about us. I mean that's, that's it's,
it's new in the sense that this generation of which we belong has become very
interested in these kinds of questions. But Bruce told me this preoccupation.
It's not really new. In fact, at least in book form,
it goes back way longer than you think. 1605 well,
before wrestling and before Fleetwood Mac and before Jimmy Fallon began laughing
at his own jokes, there was Miguel Servon, his book Don Quixote. Yeah.
So the first book really is about authenticity from like from the get go,
you opened this book Don Quixote by Miguel de Seventies and right away the
narrator says,
I'm going to tell you a story which I actually gathered from other authors from
a bunch of different historical documents. So I'm not really the author.
He says things like, well, some books say the first adventure was this,
and some say that. So even from the start,
you have a very unreliable narrator who then proceeds to tell the story of a
very unreliable, if not completely crazy, he character don Quixote,
who is dry with capricious and filled with in constant thoughts,
never imagined about anyone else.
So Don Quixote believes that he has been set on earth to rescue widows,
princesses, and P and be kind to orphans. He's like a delusional,
totally delusional. And he is. He's essentially a guy who's,
who's read too many Zane Gray novels and decides he needs to be a cowboy.
He thinks herds of sheep are attacking armies. He thinks windmills are giants.
At the same time, he has this savvy assistant,
central Panto who seems to know what's really going on and they're constantly
arguing about what's real and what's not. And then in chapter eight,
something really strange happens one day,
Don Quixote and Santo pans are traveling down the road and they see a carriage
with a woman inside just an ordinary woman going, you know, to meet her husband,
Don Quixote, whatever, for no reason at all. Uh,
the size that she is a woman in distress needs to be rescued.
And he spies this man standing right next to the carriage. He's,
he's a Basque guy, sees this guy and he decides that he's a,
he's an enemy who needs to be confronted. And so they start fighting.
Don Quixote was charging the, where it Basque with his sword on high,
determined to cut him in half. And the Basque was waiting for him.
His sword also raised and in mid swing when both swords are in the air,
the narrator stops and says, and I don't know where this goes from there,
I've run out of material and you just sort of stopped scenario and this is what,
16 oh something 1605 the book stops. It's just stopped me.
That's the end of the book. Well, no.
So you turn the page and you're in a new chapter and now the narrators is
telling you how as luck would have it,
he found this manuscript one day when I was in the OCA, not market until late.
Crazily enough. He's out a bizarre, I guess what have you.
I was shopping kind of buys and he sees this pile of old papers and books
together in a basket and he's rifling through it and he sees a picture of
[inaudible]. I was astounded and filled with anticipation there.
IPAAS apparently a real historical account in which the stupendous battle
between the governed busk and the valiant man chicken has concluded.
The problem was it was in Arabic.
And so then he hires a local Maurisco who is a Christianized more to translate
it for him. Alright,
so you now got a guy who's writing a book from historical sources.
He's run out of one, he's found another, but now that one has to be translated.
And on top of that you frequently inserts commentary about the translation.
And we'll say stuff like, well, [inaudible] says this,
but we all know that Arabs can't be trusted. So you know,
take that for what that's worth. That doesn't, I'm reading and I'm thinking,
wait a second.
This was written in 1605 what did people make of a book that didn't seem to have
any author, had author upon author upon offer?
Like were they horrified what I'm, the book was a bestseller.
It was hugely popular.
Apparently people found all these layers and these ambiguities a laugh riot.
Oh yeah. They gobbled up and they left as hard as they could.
This is Howard Manson, Savante scholar at Purdue and doe.
Kyoto was translated into English in 1612 into French in 1614 into Italian in
1622 everybody read it, including in the new world, by the way,
how many copies of the first edition of donkey hilltoppers were shipped to the
colonies? Wow. So the book is a world wide bestseller,
maybe the first of its kind. I meant 10 years later, 10 years later,
sort of on these rights, a sequel,
which kicks up this narrative weirdness to a completely new level. In part two,
part two, Don Quixote of lunch,
he introduces a new character named Samson Carrasco.
He actually visits Donkey Hill Day in sand show to tell them that part one
exists. It's a bestseller. And so in the very early chapters,
or part two donkey halt this.
So it'd be like walking up to huckleberry Finn and says, oh, by the way,
you're living here in Hannibal, Missouri. But you're now a famous boy.
That's exactly what happened. Everybody he meets,
knows who he is because they've read part one and now it gets even stranger.
Because in real life,
during that 10 years that it took of days to write his second book,
a person who goes by the pseudonym of Alonzo Fernandez, day of Ayurveda,
published his own second part of Don Quixote before Serantes could get his own
second part out. Wait, so this is, this is an unofficial part too.
Today we'd recognize it as, as, as sort of fanfiction or,
or somebody's attempting to steal George Lucas's idea and come up with our own
star wars installment. So there's this unauthorized part to floating around.
Miguel on days is very annoyed by it, I'm assuming.
So in his official sequel to Don Quixote,
there is this scene where Don Quixote is at an inn and he overhears a character
talking about his relationship with, with this, suppose that Don Quixote.
Wait, so this guy,
this guy that Simon Adler who sat in on the interview with me,
this guy existed in the fake Quixote.
Number two is a character in that and is now appearing in the real Jay.
Number two Serantes serantes steals him. If you're gonna steal my character,
I'll steal yours back right now.
You got the real bunk yoke that he's bumping into a character stolen from a fake
book of donkey. Okay, so,
so why don't you hook it then decides to confront this person.
He might just drive up to the guy and he says,
I am Don Quixote of La Mancha,
the same one who is on the lips of fame and not that unfortunate man who has
water to use their my name and bring honor to himself with my thoughts. And so,
and it's the climax of that scene, which is just wonderful, is he?
He forces this other character who he's stolen from the unauthorized CQL who
cirrhotics has stolen to admit that the donkey haute, they,
he knows from the unauthorized sequel is not the real one.
And that the one he's currently talking to is the real one.
I am co yoke grace for the sake of what you owe to your being a gentleman to
please make a statement to the magistrate of this village.
And as a matter of fact, he, he forces him to sign an affidavit to that effect.
Okay. So he busts him, he busts him, right? In the novel, in the novel,
you've got a story about a guy that then becomes a part to a story about the
story about the guy,
including false guys inside the story about the false guys from another book.
Right?
So why even bother trying to figure out what's real. Exactly right.
Anything like this come before this. No.
He's really sort of inventing this whole meta-narrative game that,
that is so popular today. You met a narrative. What, what of, well,
up until that point, most stories are simply,
they purport to be what they are. I'm telling you a story, but don't key haute.
They pretends to be something other than what it is.
It really is the start of modernity, our modern sense of the world.
So yogi with Jad, Ben, and this is like, this is,
this is not co Waxton Wayne this particular year or because I will,
it has weight. It has waxed and waned. I mean,
the donkey Hook Day has been read by different generations for different
reasons.
Bruce says he thinks the people who were reading the book originally at the time
have survived this. They actually reveled in, in the the multilevels of fiction.
They loved the metastases,
but during the romantic period and and well into the early 20th century,
people were less interested in all these narrative layers and they were more
just thrilled by the romantic don Quixote or the dream or Don Quixote.
This generation of which we belong has become very interested in this terrain
that serantes charted a long time ago.
You see it in the cinema of the late nineties in movies like the Matrix and then
later adaptation of that inception, flooring,
the concept of a dream within a dream.
See it in Seinfeld, what's going on,
what we're going to shoot the pilot and then it's going to be on TV the
following way. Yeah. Oh, there's this comedian Jerry Seinfeld,
who's playing a character that happens to be called Jerry Seinfeld,
who's making a show within the show about a character who's,
who's Jerry Seinfeld.
And so you have reality nested three times.
But I guess I'm interested in this idea of why is,
how is this happening again and why is it happening again? Well,
my sense of things is that both of these moments are moments of intellectual
crisis. Back in the Servon, this time coming out of the renaissance,
you have all of this new scientific knowledge that is calling into question the
foundation that everybody was building their lives on.
So suddenly the earth is no longer the center of the universe.
It's now just one planet among several orbiting the sun.
So you have people coming to terms with a worldview that they can no longer
sustain. And as for us now, in the last hundred years, you have Darwinism,
you have relativity, you have quantum physics.
I mean cognitive scientists are telling us that we have no free will because
they can sort of chart the chemical reaction that happens milliseconds before
we, we think we decided to do something.
All of these things tell us that the world that we think we see is not what it
is. And I think that inspires people to then start asking these questions. If,
if what I'm seeing is not real, what is, who am I?
And so I think to a great extent it's,
it's a reaction to a moment of intellectual crisis. Wait, but okay,
let's say that I like professional wrestling a lot.
I don't know anything about any of the research you're telling me about why the
hell do I like professional wrestling and why did I like it more when they
started blurring these lines? Hard question.
Well, I would say humans are humans and one of the things that we do is,
is as opposed to as far as we know,
what other animals on this planet do is we are aware of our own contingency.
Meaning we can imagine radically different possibilities.
We could imagine worlds where we don't exist or maybe we only think we exist.
I can remember
being a a child four and five years old and going to a fabric store with my
mother.
And there were two mirrors set against opposite walls and I was just fascinated
at standing in between them and watching the infinite regress go in each
direction. Um, you know, and I, I had not even started kindergarten yet.
So I think,
I think humans have this fascination with infinite regress and with embededness
and with the questions that it forces you to consider,
like where does everything begin and where does it all come from? I mean,
the question at the heart of donkey realizing
that he's a character in a novel is who stands above you.
The author stands above you.
And so that author has a kind of godlike relationship to you,
but that very question starts to make you ask who stands above that author?
And if you start asking that question, it goes on forever in every direction.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] thank you to Rupert Boyd for coming and playing the Spanish guitar
for us in the space on very short notice and to recorded books for giving us
permission to use George Greenhouse's. Wonderful read of the book.
[inaudible] he's really good. Okay, well, I guess we should go then.
We should say you should go goodbye. Say Goodbye.